الدخول الى قريه روبوتين الاستراتيجيه
هكذا ارادت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تصوره
انتصار في معارك الهجوم المضاد وتحديدا في
خط المواجهه بسبوريا
من المبكر اخماد هذه الجبهه المهمه لجميع
اطراف النزاع في السر يشكك اقرب حلفاء
اكياف في نجاح الهجوم المضاد الذي بدا
مطلع يونيو الماضي لكنها الحرب وليس كل ما
يقال في الكواليس يشعر به في العالم
والصراع الذي لا يعرف هدنه منذ 18 شهرا
يستعير في الجبهات المشتعله ويراد له ان
يتعدى حدود اوكرانيا الى داخل العمق
الروسي اعلن حاكم موسكو اسقاط مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين غرب العاصمه الروسيه وشمل
غربها حديث عن اضرار في احد المباني
السكنيه بسبب تحطم الطائرتين من جهتها
اكدت وزاره الروسيه تصدي دفاعاتها
لمسييرتين في مقاطعه بريونسكا الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وافشال عمليه التوغل داخل ترابها
على الارض الاوكرانيه وبحسب سلطتكيف
استهدفت القوات الروسيه ما لا يقل عن 30
قريه وبلده في مقاطعه زبولوجيا خلال
الساعات الاخيره الماضيه بنصر دبلوماسي
اخر يتبهر رئيس فلودي ماذا سيقدم او يؤخر
اعلان مشترك بتوقيع احدى عشره دوله من
البلقان اعرب القاده عن دعمهم الثابت
لاستقلال اوكرانيا وسيادتها ووحده اراضيها
ضمن الحدود المعترف بها دوليا ومواجهه
العدوان الروسي كان ذلك في قمه باثنا
حضرها وهو سعيد بما حصل عليه من وعودا
اثناء جولته الاوروبيه التي شملت السويد
والدنمارك وهولندا تعهد له ايضا رئيس
الوزراء اليوناني كرياكوس ميتو تاكيس
بالمساعده في تدريب طياري مقاتلات 16
الاوكرانيين واعاده اعمار اديسون بين
الدعم اللامتناهي بالسلاح وغيره والرغبه
في عدم اطلاق اخر رصاصه على الجهود
الدبلوماسيه يتارجح الموقف الاوروبي
تصريحات الممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد قبل ايام قليله كانت بدرجه
الرسائل وايضا ردود مبطنه وفق بوريل تريد
الدول الاوروبيه التوصل الى مفاوضات سلام
بشان اوكرانيا مؤكدا في نفس الوقت ان رفض
تسليح اوكرانيا لن يجلب السلام كلام
الاوروبيين عن المفاوضات مجرد تكتيك لمنح
القوات الاوكرانيه المنهكه وقتا لاستعاده
انفاسها هكذا علقت موسكو الحرب المفتوحه
على كل انواع الاسلحه والصفقات
الدبلوماسيه العابره للقارات حتى قبل ان
تضع اوزارها غيرت خريطه التحالفات وقد
تغيرها اكثر